it's a wonderful life was directed by
Frank Capra and stars Jimmy Stewart and
Donna Reed came out in 1946 and although
it initially flopped at the box office
the film has eventually gained such a
following that it's become a holiday
tradition it was nominated for a few
Oscars and just like a Christmas story
the film plays every single Christmas
now on television and it's become
something that's very special for a lot
of families around the world I didn't
actually see this film when I was a kid
though and it took me a while to see it
for the first time the first time I ever
heard about It's a Wonderful Life was
actually on the Batman animated series
[Music]
in its place is the following Joker here
greetings Gotham and Merry Christmas I
hope you're watching Batman this one's
for you
[Laughter]
[Music]
the Christmas with the Joker episode was
always one of my favorites it was on
this VHS tape that I had when I was a
kid and I had never seen it's a
wonderful life at that point and so I
remember as the Joker referenced it I
thought to myself oh well that must be
like something special if it's on the
Batman show this you know I was like
five years old at the time and the first
time I saw it I was over at a friend's
house on some Christmas Eve and I was
channel surfing and I came across
probably the most intense part of the
movie it's the sequence where Jimmy
Stewart's is discovering that his life
means nothing his life has been taken
away completely and this angel has shown
him what the world would be like without
him and he runs towards the screen into
a close-up in this amazing performance
and I remember being hooked and I
thought to myself this seems like a
really damn good movie I need to watch
the whole thing
this film follows George Bailey played
by Stewart and we first meet him as a
young kid with a ton of dreams as an
adult though he's very frustrated in
life because he's taken over his
father's business it's this loan company
and he's trying to help people in the
town he's getting people money when they
need it he's helping them find houses he
doesn't really realize how much good
he's actually doing for the people in
his life because to him he's always
wanted to travel he's always wanted to
go see the world he has so many hopes
and dreams but he hasn't been able to
accomplish any of them and so despite
all the good he's done in his life he
feels like he hasn't achieved what he
wants to do there's this business tycoon
in the town named Potter who's the
executive of these slums and he's always
taking money from people and he's always
trying to take over this business but
George Bailey doesn't let him and so the
town appreciates that and the town loves
him for that but still he feels like he
doesn't have what he needs because he
has all of these goals despite the fact
that he has a lovely wife and great kids
and so that part that I first saw when I
was channel surfing when I was younger
is when he decides that things aren't
going so well for him in life and he
feels the need to end his life and an
angel named Clarence is sent down to
earth to show him what life would be
like if he had never existed
so the message behind the film which has
remained timeless is that you should be
happy with what you have and sometimes
it's easy to look past what's right in
front of you and not accept your current
situation
and think that you don't have enough and
that you're only ever going to be happy
if you achieve other things in the
future and if you maintain that
viewpoint throughout life you'll
probably never be fully happy because
you're always trying to achieve
something and once you achieve it it's
like what's the next thing and I can
totally understand that because that's
actually the exact type of person that I
am I always feel like I have to do
something better than what I've done
before and that's a good mentality you
know if you're an artist or someone who
just really wants to work really hard
there's this drive to want to always be
better than you were before and and
that's positive but if you take the
viewpoint that George Bailey has where
your life is a complete and utter
failure unless you are doing exactly
what you want to do well then you're
never going to be happy and that's one
of the reasons that I love this movie
and why I find it so inspirational
because it actually does speak to me
quite a bit it's something that I feel
very inspired by whenever I watch it
because by all accounts and purposes I
am NOT doing what I want to do right now
I'll just be totally real with you guys
I would love to be full-time directing
movies and right now I'm doing that
completely part-time and they're they're
short films and I'm submitting them to
festivals right now and I'm trying to
get some note as a filmmaker and I'm
trying really hard to work on that but
full time right now is movie reviews I
don't want to be doing that for the rest
of my life and that's the honest truth
but I shouldn't be unhappy because of
that I've garnered an amazing following
of people that are watching this right
now that I'm so grateful for I have a
wonderful wife and a family and all of
these things are things that I can be
happy for and it usually takes
Christmastime and a movie like gets a
wonderful life to remind me of that and
and this is just me being totally real
and transparent with you guys and and
that's one of the reasons this movie is
so special to me because it is one of
those few films that really does make me
look at my life in retrospect and I
think it does that for a lot of people
and I think that's one of the reasons
why it's so inspirational so personal
stuff aside unlike a lot of films from
the 40s It's a Wonderful Life is really
fast moving despite being over two hours
it really doesn't feel like that
the
scenes move quick and the actors are
giving performances that feel real they
don't feel like those old 1930s 1940s
performances everybody talk like this or
talk really fast hey you only some money
and I'm gonna get that money from you if
it's the last thing I do like no one in
the movie talks like that everyone feels
very real also the set holy crap this
set is insane it's one of the biggest
sets ever at the time it covered a few
acres actually the set for this town
I was actually kind of blown away when I
learned it was a set I mean they had so
much to work with so many buildings that
could film camera movements and things
that they could set up within this set
that that made it's such a realistic
looking place they used a new kind of
snow in the film as well at the time
cornflakes were mostly used for snow but
they didn't want to use cornflakes
because it made a lot of noise so they
developed a new form of fake movie snow
so they could record the sound live and
they would have to do less ADR and post
which makes for better performances and
more realistic audio and these are all
technical choices this shows a great
amount of planning and care that was
given to this production more so than
just Jimmy Stewart or Donna Reed's great
performances or Frank Capra's great
direction this is really really good
filmmaking there's been many times where
I've heard of older films for years
they've been talked about they've been
voted really high on various lists and
then I see the film and I think well
that was good but I probably don't
really feel like watching that again or
it just seems a little bit overrated
it's a wonderful life as one of the few
that really doesn't feel that way to me
I think this is a timeless movie that
people are going to enjoy watching and
actually have a really good time
watching with their families for
continuing decades I'm gonna give It's a
Wonderful Life an A+ it's been really
fun to do this series with you guys and
reflect back on some really great films
and a couple not-so-great films that are
famous for other reasons this has been
really really nice and thank you very
much for for taking this journey with me
I hope you enjoyed the series I have new
ideas for next year
I kind of want to do something that's
not so locked down like there's a lot of
times where I feel like reviewing an
older film and it's not part of any
series or it's not related to any
franchise that's coming out and I I
don't have an excuse to review it I
might just take next year and just have
each month be like some random older
movie it has nothing to do with anything
coming out at the time and I can cover
some things I've always wanted to talk
about on this channel guys whatever you
celebrate this time of year even if it's
just the fact that you're not having to
go to work for a few days or school for
a few days I hope you have a good one
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]